atravesar La Peligrosa selva del Darién
a pie no les asusta en el pequeño pueblo
de necoclí en la costa caribeña de
Colombia al menos 10.000 migrantes solo
tienen una cosa en mente llegar al
pueblo de acandí luego a Panamá a
Centroamérica y finalmente a Estados
Unidos hay muchas cosas que han dicho el
Darién pero si la mayoría pase yo tengo
que vivir la experiencia para ver qué
tal me me vaya porque todos salimos
algunos salen vivos no se los demás Pero
algunos migrantes están bloqueados por
falta de barcos y otros por falta de
dinero incluso algunas mujeres están
sometiendo a la explotación sexual para
poder pagar el viaje este año el flujo
de inmigrantes en intentar la travesía
ya es superior al registrado en todo
2021 que ya había superado al de toda la
década anterior este año la crisis
migratoria es mucho más grave que la
registrada al año pasado primero porque
la cantidad de personas posibilidad
humana que han pasado hacia Panamá
supera los 150.000 personas en
comparación con los 134 mil migrantes en
todo el año 2021 Colombia está en el
camino de muchos migrantes que se
dirigen a Norteamérica a finales de 2021
la última afluencia de exiliados fue
principalmente de haitianos la ruta del
Darién una selva densa inhóspita es una
de las más peligrosas del mundo y dura
entre 3 y 4 días